this episode of fun science is brought
to you by Skillshare it's no secret that
I love my cats however I do sometimes
wonder dogs are apparently man's best
friend while cats are considered to be
cold and mean people are always arguing
about cats versus dogs and though my cat
does seem to love me could it be
possible that I picked the wrong pet
seems like a debate for science to try
and settle once and for all in this
episode of fun side it's fun it's fun
science decide ya can't dunk your first
topic it's helps easy all one has to do
is have a feline around and will lower
your risk of death from heart attack by
30% Wow dogs do that too but we only
lower at 33% doc that's three percent
more than can't an arbitrary difference
well cats lower stress levels through
touch alone oh so do dogs and we're
proven to increase a human's physical
activity because we need lots of walks
and there's plenty of science showing
that dogs can attack some types of
cancer by sniffing human sample and
that's health dog is in the lead but
it's still anyone's game
next intelligence well everyone knows
cats are way smarter than dogs dogs have
five hundred and thirty million cortical
neurons in their brains and cats have
um 250 that's less than half and humans
have way more we've got 16 billion
cortical neurons playing or anything
next up love I win next topic
oh come on don't get catch off here
proof of my love thank you
go ahead test the saliva for oxytocin
levels that is the hormone and that is
released when you're experiencing love
hello many scientists say that oxytocin
is more of a social information Oh to me
to me okay can't your saliva showed a
12% increase in oxytocin yes see I do
love you and dog your saliva showed a
57.2% increase makes worldwide impacts
well cats are smaller on average so we
eat less which means that there is less
carbon dioxide emissions in the air due
to meat production
so we're basically saving the planet but
don't you murder birds dogs don't do
that right cat though it is difficult to
estimate
studies show that cats kill between 1.3
and 3.7 billion birds per year well at
least were cheaper the average american
cat owner spends an estimated fifty six
dollars a year on cat treats whereas the
dog owner spends 72 well maybe we just
deserve more treats because we're such
good boys okay
that is time now the results okay I've
made my decision and can now reveal that
the pet I should have gotten from the
start is
[Music]
cats because ultimately the pet you end
up with is likely linked to your
personality one study has shown that
people who own cats tend to be more
introverted and neurotic like myself or
people who own dogs score higher for
extraversion and agreeableness so I win
at least as far as my heart is concerned
cats yes
you wouldn't so while there are many
variables you could factor in when
choosing between a cats or a dog your
decision might be down to something you
can't change your personality but
objectively dogs are better that's rough
but maybe you've already figured out
which plan is best for you and always
looking for ways to take your
relationship with your furry friend to
the next level well guess what there is
a Skillshare course for that perhaps
you'd like to learn how to immortalize
your pets in a portrait or maybe
recreate them as a plush toy
well the online learning community
Skillshare has loads of creative courses
like these to explore though obviously
they're not all pet related and the
first 500 people to sign up to
Skillshare using the link in the
description will get their first two
months for free so why not start now
personally I might check out this course
on cat photography because well everyone
has their passions anyway thank you so
much for watching and I'll see you next
time bye bye